[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale nous sommes le mercredi 27 avril
voici les titres les villes sont de plus
en plus nombreuses à lancer leur budget
participatif une initiative qui permet
aux habitants de proposer des projets
pour la ville objectif laisser les
citoyens s'expriment et être acteur de
la vie municipale les exemples
d'elancourt et villepreux dans ce
journal si la fibre est opérationnel
depuis un an à montigny le bretonneux
beaucoup d' incidents surviennent
coupures ou encore panne des problèmes
qui serait due à la sous traitance des
opérateurs face à la dégradation du
réseau la ville a décidé d'agir et puis
l'élection de miss supranational aura
lieu au mois de juin l'un des plus
grands concours de beauté au monde
auquel participe la sixième lors à omni
les biennoises de 25 ans se prépare pour
l'événement son portrait en fin de
journal
[Musique]
c'est la tendance les villes sont de
plus en plus nombreuses à lancer leur
budget participatif comme maurepas
verneuil sur seine ou encore choisel le
principe permettre aux habitants de
proposer leurs idées sur différentes
thématiques sport culture ou encore
environnement à villepreux quatre
projets seront retenus et financés par
la mairie un reportage de mathilde de
franck ou participer à l'amélioration du
cadre de vie générer du lien social
contribué au vivre ensemble ce sont les
principes essentiels pour qu'un projet
soit retenu par la mairie de villepreux
la ville lance son premier budget
participatif avec une enveloppe de 25000
euros ça faisait partie des engagements
de campagne de la liste villepreux
naturellement dont l'équipe municipale
est issu donc pour nous c'est essentiel
de mettre en place cette promesse
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
confiance et de défiance envers la
politique et au niveau look locale en
tout cas si on peut par
par le respect de la parole donnée aux
électeurs contribuer à renforcer ce lien
de proximité entre les élus et les
habitants ont dû contribuer santé
jeunesse sport transition écologique les
habitants ont jusqu'au 15 mai pour
déposer leurs idées au total quatre
projets seront retenus je trouve que
c'est une bonne initiative a dès
l'instant où on fait participer les
citoyens tels qu'ils soient dans quelque
domaine que ce soit ça me paraît une
bonne initiative j'étais pas au courant
comme je voulais ni mais enfin bon
priori oui c'est une bonne initiative ce
qui serait bien à mon avis
c'est qu'on fasse à un peu plus pour les
jeunes gens n'y a pas assez d espace où
les jeunes peuvent se rassembler pour
s'amuser peuvent prendre du temps voilà
alors que c'est vrai que les structures
sportives existent
mais tout le monde n'a pas forcément
accès moi j'appuie sur une chose c'est
que ce serait vraiment pas mal de
d'utiliser ce budget pour les activités
des enfants les idées foisonnent
lorsqu'on va à la rencontre des
habitants la ville de villepreux a déjà
reçu quelques dossiers alors on a des
projets qui devraient arriver notamment
sur l'éducation à la jeunesse a annoncé
que c'est des thématiques qui sont qui
sont fortes en ce moment donc on n'a pas
le détail précis des projets encore on
sait que ça devrait être ça devrait être
de thématiques publicité par les portant
de projets les villes prévient et les
villes proviennent peuvent déposer leurs
idées par mail ou par courrier à la
mairie pour proposer son projet c'est
simple il suffit de remplir ce
formulaire disponible à l'hôtel de ville
au sur le site internet de villepreux
nom du projet objectifs thématiques les
dossiers seront ensuite étudiées par la
ville puis voté du 17 au 27 juin
[Musique]
on parle donc de budget participatif
c'est à dire laisser lé citoyen
s'exprimer au travers de projets pour la
commune et ça se fait de plus en plus on
vient on en voit un exemple dans ce
reportage et pour continuer sur le sujet
on va accueillir thierry michel qui est
avec nous avons soir bonsoir vous êtes
vous mais l'adjoint délégué aux finances
aux travaux et à l'événementiel
d'elancourt la ville d'elancourt et vous
êtes avec nous puisque justement la
ville d'elancourt a décidé de lancer son
tout premier budget participatif depuis
le mi avril 15 avril exact et pourquoi
finalement se lancer là-dedans bas le
budget partie physique pour nous c'est
un moment de concertation et puis de
permettre à la population de vivre un
peu plus la ville donc c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est lancé dans cette aventure et
donc pour cette initiative elle
s'adresse à tous dès 11 ans concrètement
comment ça va pas se passer est-ce qu'on
peut peut-être faire un point sur le
planning et les différentes étapes à
venir ou alors vous parlez de dépasser
nos onze on ira jusqu'à 111 ans qu'on
voulait donc on a dit qu'on serait très
très large dans la population et le
planning des lancers parce
qu'effectivement depuis le 15 avril et
jusqu'au 15 juin c'est le dépôt des
dossiers sur un site dédié tout se fait
en ligne une fois cette période passée
nous aurons une période de combats
qualifiés de technique un don qui va
partir du 15 juin jusqu'à la
mi-septembre ou là ce sont nos
techniciens juriste financier
techniciens de bâtiments et autres qui
vont regarder la faisabilité du projet
parce que c'est pas tout déposer un
projet il faut qu'ils puissent être
réalisés à y est enfin on passera dans
une phase qui sera certainement la plus
importante celle au vote le vote de la
population qui va se dire bah voilà ils
attendent projet moi je suis intéressé
par ceux ci pour mon quartier ou pour un
autre quartier et je vote enfin il y
aura la publication des résultats qui
sera un grand moment pour ceux qui vont
être l'horaire voir leur projet peut
être réalisé et vote on y reviendra
aussi dans quelques instants mais
justement je voulais voir avec vous
puisque le dépôt des projets finalement
vous l'aï dit est cadré et il doit
rentrer dans une des trois catégories
suivantes c'est à dire le cadre de vie
environnement c'est une catégorie la
jeunesse il en est une autre et puis
sports et loisirs pourquoi ces
catégories finalement certainement des
éléments qui intéressent le plus la
population aujourd'hui c'est normal ils
vont se retrouver si c'est pour leur
proposer de faire des projets pour faire
de la voirie je pense pas que ça c'est
intéressant ça c'est ce qu' ils vivent
tous les jours c'est leur manière de
vivre la ville c'est pour ça qu'on a
créé ces trois catégories et donc pour
pour continuer un petit peu donner un
peu des contraintes aussi au projet il
ya un règlement on peut retrouver sur le
site internet du coup d'elancourt quels
sont les critères principaux quelles
sont les contraintes pour que le projet
soit accepté donc on situ 3 d'abord
l'intérêt général on fait pas un projet
pour soi on fait un projet pour toute la
population après il ya un critère de
prix le projet ne peut pas dépasser 35
500 euros ensuite il faut qu'il se fasse
sur un bien public on va pas aller faire
un projet sur un territoire privé et
puis il faut l'argumenter ce projet fou
de nous à les dire nous le vendre il
faut que la personne explique
effectivement pourquoi elle souhaite
faire ce projet pour être plus précis
possible soit d'accord puisqu'on palais
sur place un petit peu pour voir les
personnes ont le droit de se déplacer
d'aller voir de faire des mesures s'il
souhaite et justement ça est l'intérêt
de ce budget participent c'est d'aller
un peu plus loin ça veut dire match
j'aimerais faire ça c'est de le préparer
dans son ensemble près de nous
l'accompagnons naturellement donc tout
un travail comme tout autre oeil et ses
projets sa force aussi finalement à
s'intéresser à la commune à devenir
acteur de la vie municipale est-ce que
c'était ça aussi un peu l'objectif
derrière cette initiative oui c'est une
autre manière de vivre sa vie l'un
aujourd'hui bon on est souvent sur les
crèches les écoles les équipements
sportifs à travers le monde associatif
la cci intéressés sous une forme avec
cet aspect budgétaire qui va être
effectivement un élément nouveau même si
on a tous dans sa vie privée à gérer un
budget là c'est une approche un peu
différente et ça va permettre le côté
pédagogique de dire mais voilà une ville
c'est géré on va vous avez un conseil
municipal qui prend des décisions ben
voilà les réflexions qu'ils ont au
quotidien et ça permet de comprendre un
peu mieux le mécanisme de la gestion du
budget de la ville et ça permet de voir
du coup l'envers du décor on n'est pas
mon courant de tout ce qui se passe
effectivement effectivement parce que
gérer une ville c'est pas simple on a
deux grandes notions dans le budget le
fonctionnement quotidien et les
investissements là on va sur le budget
d'investissement d'ailleurs on réserve
une somme de cent cinquante mille euros
pour ce projet de budget participatif
très bien et donc vous l'avez dit on va
on va revenir là dessus donc une
enveloppe de cent cinquante mille euros
pour ce budget comment il va être
répartie alors finalement on attend de
voir les projets comme on l'a dit donc
c'est 37 500 euros maximum pourquoi pas
ce que c'est on veut plusieurs projets
c'est pas de faire ce projet ça n'a pas
d'intérêt l'idée c'est d'avoir plusieurs
projets si possible répartis sur tous
les quartiers de la ville c'est là
l'intérêt de ce concept de budget
participatif donc leur a pas qu'un seul
projet a finalement choisi peut y en
avoir quatre voire cinq si tout le monde
ne va pas jusque
pascal ont finalement c'est parce qu'on
va avoir du projet aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on a déjà une dizaine de dossiers qui
ont été déposés depuis 15 avril depuis
le 15 avril donc on s'en va intéresser
gérer avec ce projet après ma il va
faire chiffrer donc c'est là où on va
voir là peut-être y en aura un de plus
mais pour l'instant c'est un peu trop
tôt pour pouvoir se prononcer là vous
dit si vous avez déjà une dizaine de
projets de dire que finalement c'était
peut-être un besoin c'était peut-être me
demande aussi du territoire alors oui il
ya une attente aujourd'hui de s'investir
plus dans la gestion de sa ville parce
qu'il ya le quotidien je dire que les
gens vivent la population et dima tient
là il ya peut-être besoin de ceux-ci là
il ya besoin de cela nous on est des
fois on est sur des grands projets et
par ce quotidien on vient intéressé
effectivement la population à nous dire
est ce qu'on pourra faire ci est ce
qu'on pouvait faire ça et c'est là où
effectivement c'est un accompagnement
finalement est ce que vous auriez des
exemples exemples de projets qu'on
pourrait voir fleurir sur la commune il
ya des demandes dans le domaine sportif
qui peuvent être autour de city stade
vous savez c'est une attente par exemple
de notre jeune public de pouvoir
s'amuser régulièrement on va avoir
certainement des choses autour du
fleurissement la table beaucoup
d'attentes dans ces domaines ça peut
être aussi des problèmes de sécurité on
va nous demander des passages piétons
des stations gonflage par exemple pour
les vélos sacre développe lui sur
lancôme aussi sur saint quentin les
pistes cyclables ben oui si on a un
petit souci comment fait donc on peut
avoir des projets divers et variés et
donc on le rappellera à ses projets
peuvent être déposées jusqu'au 15 juin
2022 et dont vous l'avez dit seront
soumis à un vote du 15 octobre au 15
novembre finalement donc on sait pas le
nombre de projets qui peuvent être
retenus mais comment va s'effectuer ce
choix melilla de participation du coût
des élans courtois ah oui c'est désolant
pour toi
uniquement qui vont décider qui vont
voter les élus du conseil municipal ne
se prononceront pas on se prononcer sur
la gestion du budget de la ville donc
c'est pas pour s'approprier ce budget au
contraire c'est à dire allez-y
appropriez vous ce budget voté prenez de
vraies décisions prenez les décisions
pour votre commune c'est super donc du
coup ce sera lancée peut-être les
projets début 2023 exactement on aura le
temps de excusez-moi de l'analyse une
fois que les projets seront validées sur
le plan technique appelons les prendre à
moi et on essaiera dans le programme des
travaux de la ville donc on pourrait
parfois à fleurir prochaine on vous le
rappelle a en tout cas les dossiers
peuvent être déposés jusqu'au 15 juin
2022 merci beaucoup thierry michel
d'avoir été atteint chez nous je le
rappelle un vous êtes maire-adjoint
délégué aux finances aux travaux et à
l'événementiel de la ville d'elancourt
[Musique]
62 millions d'euros c'est le budget
investi par le département pour le vélo
est votée le 22 avril lors de la
dernière assemblée ce plan vélo
s'établit sur la période de 2022 à 2027
l'objectif principal c'est promouvoir et
faciliter la pratique du vélo au
quotidien il ya plusieurs aux axes
principaux la réalisation d'un réseau
cyclable de 1350 km à l'horizon 2027 le
développement de l'offre des services
sur le département et puis
l'accessibilité des infrastructures
telles que les gars les établissements
scolaires ou encore les sites olympiques
de 2024 un investissement donc de 62
millions d'euros au total divisé en deux
parties 50 millions d'euros qui seront à
dédiées aux différents aménagements
notamment de liaisons douces pour le
vélo et puis le reste du budget une
enveloppe de 12 millions d'euros sera
dédié aux communes pour développer
l'offre locale
et puis à montigny le bretonneux cela
fait un an que le réseau de fibre est
opérationnel mais de nombreux incidents
sont trop souvent signalés par les
habitants en cause les armoires qui sont
régulièrement dégradé par des
entreprises sous-traitantes des
opérateurs face aux multiples
contraintes complainte des administrés à
la municipalité a décidé de réagir et
les explications de mathilde de francs
coup et c'est charles
des armoires qui permettent de conduire
la fibre jusqu'au domicile des aînés
montant constamment dégradé coupure
panne la ville de montigny le bretonneux
et ses habitants n'en peuvent plus
malheureusement nous avons affaire à des
sous traitants qui pour un certain
nombre sont peu scrupuleux laisse les
armoires ouvertes des branches
pour brancher leur client ne remettent
pas ensuite les
les fils et les branchements tels qu'ils
étaient avant qu'il intervienne début
avril une pétition a été lancée par une
habitante elle compte une vingtaine de
signatures sur le quartier ça fait neuf
fois que coca mais coupée alors il y en
a il y en a où parfois si par
inadvertance d'autres fois c'est
volontaire mais ils vont pas de
l'admettre je suis allé voir mes voisins
en leur disant que je pensais écrire à
la mairie il n'y a pas un seul voisin
dziennik vue qui a refusé de signer la
pétition relevant du domaine privé la
ville n'est pas responsable de ces
armoires mais elle a tout de même
souhaité agir suite aux multiplications
des complaintes une réunion entre quatre
grands opérateurs et le maire laurin
merker a eu lieu le 22 avril dernier
face à l'absence de réponse concrète la
municipalité a pris des mesures j'ai
pris la décision de fermer un certain
nombre d'armoires celles qui étaient
plus dégradée en instance et à un
système de cadenas dessus est dorénavant
il ya une affiche que l'on a imposé sur
cette armoire qui indique à l'opérateur
est en sous traitant qui doit se rendre
à la police municipale retirer la clé
donné son identité et la société pour
laquelle il est rien est donc mon but
devant la clé il peut intervenir il
arpente derrière des solutions qui
s'accompagne d'un engagement de principe
des opérateurs sur la formation et la
responsabilisation de leurs sous
traitants les habitants souvent en
télétravail espère pouvoir profiter de
leur connexion sans désagréments dans le
futur la municipalité restera vigilante
sur le sujet
focus à présent sur les glaces de la
maison albert elle une entreprise située
à trappes depuis 2011 elle propose des
produits bio en circuit court michael et
demi d'euros étalé la découvrir
[Musique]
le défi je les ai eues il ya très très
longtemps il y a une
une trentaine d'années j'ai commencé
dans la restauration
où je faisais mes glaces et
j'ai toujours aimé faire ça
ce qui fait que j'ai voulu nous faire
mon métier à plein temps
[Musique]
des barques fondamentalement par la
qualité et par le pourcentage de matière
que l'on à l'intérieur
[Musique]
immense vous avez 1 70% à l'intérieur du
et
un acteur de la glace le reste est une
pause une un sirop qui composent le
sucre et d'eau il n'y a rien d'autre
[Musique]
oh
bon j'ai repris 7 mai l'entreprise j'ai
vraiment à coeur de pouvoir donc offrir
à tous des produits donc avec une
traçabilité
et que le consommateur puisse réellement
savoir ce qui allait avoir dans son
assiette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
métro est un vrai partenaire pour pour
les restaurateurs est donc c'est
vraiment billets
un billet qu'on veut utiliser pour se
faire connaître et pour augmenter notre
chiffre d'affaires auprès des
restaurateurs de la région
[Musique]
direction bois d'arcy à présent lors à
omni 25 ans est en course pour devenir à
la future miss supranational france l'un
des plus grands concours de beauté au
monde aux côtés de miss univers ou
encore miss monde son portrait par
michael almy d'euros je m'appelle laura
j'ai 25 ans et je viens de bois d'arcy
et j'ai été élue miss supranational
ile-de-france 2022 depuis janvier
dernier le rapporte fièrement son
écharpe dans les rues de bois d'arcy la
jeune arcisienne d'un mètre 73 a été
sélectionné pour participer à ce
rendez-vous qui figurent dans le top 5
des concours de beauté les plus renommés
au niveau mondial un challenge avant de
devenir diplômés notaire l'année
prochaine c'est avant tout pour
concrétiser un rêve de petite fille et
je pense que comme j'étais à ma septième
année de droit c'est le moment ou jamais
de se lancer
j'ai pas fais du journalisme j'ai pas
fait de la mode donc le concours des
miss ça me permet d'avoir une petite
porte d'entrée dans ce monde et entre
voir à quoi ça ressemble actuellement
lowrie dans la dernière ligne droite
c'est ti vinoy ce passionné de voyages
et de surf participera à l'élection
nationale programmée le 5 juin prochain
roubaix elle sera face à une vingtaine
de candidates pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté la miss regarde
régulièrement les dernières éditions du
concours on a vraiment à le côté un peu
garni avec toutes les belles robes etc
qui font qu'ils font rêver les la petite
fille la petite fille qu'on en nous
outre sa je pense vraiment que c'est une
aventure c'est une aventure humaine qui
doit être incroyable je pense qu'aucune
fille regrette d'avoir participé à ce
type de concours pour remporter ce
concours lors a également décidé de
confectionner son propre costume
régional avec l'aide d'une amie
un sixième a encore un mois pour
terminer sa robe sur le thème de
versailles de marie antoinette
c'est le premier prototype il manque
après tout le tout le tissu qu'on va
mettre par dessus là c'est vraiment on
va dire le patron du costume devoir
retravailler pour avoir le costume final
un costume pour éblouir le jury et sa
famille c'est d'ailleurs avec ses
proches que laura partage son rêve et
notamment avec julia sa nièce de quatre
ans et demi
tu as vu la photo de candidature j'étais
comment sur la photo de candidature
c'est le meilleur soutien c'est le fan
club et les fans veulent les mêmes robes
des robes que laura espère porter
jusqu'à l'élection miss supranational à
l'international si elle remporte le
concours français en juin elle
s'envolera pour la pologne à la mi
juillet une 12ème édition qui réunira 76
pays sur scène devant plus de 650
millions de téléspectateurs un véritable
rêve pour les vies noise
et puis en pleine période de vacances
scolaires nous vous proposons quelques
idées et d'activités avant de terminer
ce journal le centre commercial one
nation paris ont plaidé que les sous
bois se transforme en fête foraine le
ton des vacances jusqu'au y met des
manèges investissaient les lieux
carrousel chaises volantes pêche aux
canards stands ou encore spectacles et
animations sont gratuites elles sont
ouvertes de 14h à 18h le palais du roi
de rome de rambouillet vous propose
également des activités jusqu'au 5 mai
au programme des visites contées mais
aussi des ateliers avec la création de
patrons pour des vêtements de croisière
ou encore aides des maquettes de cabines
de plage et puis les 28 avril et 5 mai
un jeu de piste sera organisée de 15
heures à 17 heures à la recherche du
chalet du barreau nivière c'est un
parcours enquête qui s'adresse au lieu
de 15 ans objectif découvrir à
rambouillet sous l'angle de la belle
époque ces ateliers activités sont
accessibles sur réservation
implantée à montigny le bretonneux le
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines vous propose des activités pour
les vacances une visite à vélo autour de
l'étang est organisée ce samedi 30 avril
à 14 heures 30 une balade de deux heures
et demie pour découvrir les histoires
autour du plan d'eau et puis à d'autres
ateliers sont bien sûr organisée la
semaine prochaine autour de la sculpture
ou encore à de la couleur orange les
activités se font également sur
réservation et puis pour terminer
partant on du côté de la verrière pour
le tournoi à dos des sites et
fantastique elle le à dos et une balle
au prisonnier nouvelle génération entre
un dragon ball z ou street fighter un
jeu en équipe qui se joue en réalité
augmentée muni d'un casque sur les yeux
d'un bracelet connecter à deux équipes
combattent à l'aide de boucliers virtuel
et boule d'énergie
la ville de la barrière vous propose
donc de découvrir ce sport vient tournoi
d'initiation et ça se passera le lundi 2
mai de 13h30 à 18h aux villes au gymnase
de la fraternité de la verrière
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver nicolas landry à la
présentation de votre 7,8 société thème
de l'émission le retour des festivals de
musique cet été très bonne soirée à tous
sur télé 78
[Musique]